misuk you guys in the human the director
of the IMAX
in the first two episodes is an
incredibly challenged element and we're
so looking on rule
[Applause]
Indian accent without word and and I was
very lucky to be able to probe our how
to another show on this where he's been
doing really masterful work in that
Scott level right
[Applause]
now we are going to introduce you to the
Inhumans growing up my favorite inhuman
and if you will go out and and uh
nemedian ventures number nine in the
back in the letter section there's
actually a letter from me right into
sand and telling you what I thought her
story ought to be about me and Anna and
my favorite character was Triton man
he's Mike
[Music]
[Applause]
being over for you they make
[Music]
and so as you probably I should probably
tell the cast encompass with I she came
to us and and and just hits asses or on
they can read the comic she's she exact
same comics and so when Sonia first came
in we just said well she's going to have
to play this part so
[Applause]
[Applause]
there's Thomas I can tell you about our
character until it's a week we're going
to tell you tell you you're just going
to fall in love as we did with Ellen
[Applause]
you know we've been cleaning a lot of
time talking about our 2010 bulldog
she's the person who has to look after I
have to tell you I was complete kicking
back because through the whole show
she's blonde and has the doughnut on the
back of her head like in the comics and
when she comes out she's not gonna look
like that but you're not any point of it
so novel and
[Applause]
and now and again I think one of the
favorite for you guys with these massive
ability can just destroy cities and
stuff and he's incredibly powerful and
we're so lucky to have discovered any
and he's just somebody here to know and
again to be truly delightful any funny
please
[Applause]
you're being lost if you're a fan of
prawns notice gentlemen I was acting
first one cast when we found out that we
were going to have Carnac in the show I
could only just see cam in the park so
[Applause]
[Music]
when you're going to have maximus
becoming fairly Maximus bad although he
might be look you know even better than
we did when we first started out and
it's been just an incredible pleasure
working with a on
[Applause]
she is our queen I saw her very briefly
responsibility for about 40 pounds of
hair that moons and wonderful and Gigi
an extraordinary actress entailed the
drama and the comedy and I just laid
them through the swamp
you
[Applause]
so you go to an actor and you sing
manager this is a great chance to play
one of those iconic characters and
marble is over 50 years old he's a king
regal it's unbelievable and by the way
there's no lines and it just never gonna
be any lines it's not like we're home by
the time they're going to do it some of
the way there's a magic surgery or
anything on the deck and I can tell you
as the character displays the activity
does just loose all the way the I can't
anomalies level
[Applause]
so welcome all of you guys some of this
coming for you is this is your first
time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I want to talk with you guys first so
rule like you got this this gig Marcus
you were insane enough to agree to go to
Hawaii or else either going to hear of
Waterloo like that on but if you shoot
in the jungle in Hawaii for months you
may have a different opinion what is so
beautiful they tell us to salute or
about it like working with the cameras
and trying to get to make something to
have that eyes in scope yes first of all
of Tunis and IMAX kind of scary
everybody in ominous I quote I miss
cameras were still like refrigerators
but that new digital ones and we are
thinking forwarded from inventions right
so before I involved I wanted to test
them out so I both a schematic to a
testing facility related in it was
throwing around people binding through
so scared showing me ship throwing this
thing around and then funny thing I
didn't have any wider lenses because I
felt lens were not wide enough for this
couple we are trying to do so they built
a special lens for us for this show and
when you see is this thing that we did
is mind-boggling
it's mind-boggling beautiful payment so
Scott like this is a whole lot of people
with superpowers we do now shows that
would you tell you only percent down no
I think that's the best approach
like this is not to see these people as
superheroes but as people or Inhumans
who happen to have a superpower and as
you people watch the show they will see
that these superpowers are not always
necessarily that that and sometimes can
actually be a crutch that they dependent
on their whole lives to be able to solve
their problems and then the story that
we created those superpowers are not
necessarily always that helpful
no it's one of the things that I got so
caught up in was this idea that the
people that live in that land were very
loyal to hope but in some ways were not
necessarily happy in that world and
anyone that's something as Maximus you
got a chance to take advantage of
practically a good one yeah yeah it's
really cool discussions got to try and
make things like this in maximum so try
to show the side when they try to
genuinely change the world and how far
the people who pleaded are living in
terrible conditions in the Cataclysm
which they had no choice over so he
believed that he should freedom and yeah
that's where you get a conflict between
the brothers anybody's right as
brother's not doing anything so he
needed to you need to do something
himself and yes that's where we kind of
find Maximus in this one so as you were
saying earlier maybe claps more of an
antagonist then
but yeah it's two opposing ideas there
are no clear villains involvement things
you have such interesting
shades for every character and the idea
was that each of the passionate
politician who wants to change things
for the better for the people and maybe
oneself
Oh Alan you win a silver surfer here so
that's more role for you you have to
lose surf over up here yeah really
quickly good yeah yeah I don't think
you're not playing the silver circle
okay so Sonja as I told everybody you
got to kick ass tell me about what that
was I like to have fun yeah I'm glad we
might can either great stunts and men
training and work amazing sent
choreographers of my crayon refers and
it had to come there is boxing lesson to
learn how to punch properly and yeah I
remember in my audition you guys asked
hey I'm the one love it
I'm like yes yes I am but my role
required my more that I instigated but
um it was a lot of fun and you know
fighting the jungle with full body was
like covered in leather that's the club
energy it was hard but worth it
enjoy a fun action things out there in
the jungle and my tactic I don't think
they know they you actually can't pick
ax I mean you play triangle we can see a
lot of fun doing that but can you just
tell this some of the titles that you
hold that corner John or people coming
I've been doing Taekwondo since I was 12
I'm a five-time world champion I have my
own school so being able to do some
action in the show and actually do it
legitimately is something that I'm very
proud of and this team like Sonia
doesn't mention she she kicked some
serious butt everybody whether they're
trained like me or not you guys you
really had to rejection
Isabelle you go to play it really the
princess in the story and a lot of your
scenes were by yourself but they weren't
by yourself because you're with the two
pounds and pound hold on yeah
so I tell us what that was like when we
told you this that most of your scenes
work with a CGI character that we were
put in the shop
yes very interesting since a lot of the
time I'm acting to the air so as make up
a great relationships with lockdoor but
if you watch me from the outside all day
like what is the girls doing crazy but
this is the body part in my information
and I wishes I were asked to you know
pretend there was a huge giant in front
of me and at the employer I didn't know
that crystal would get it you know talk
to law school so I in my position I just
started like go crazy and my place make
invisible creatures I had no idea what
it was and was rolled over cause I guess
I was running around the room like
action and that was a local client what
I did throughout the show was really fun
every day I would be friends remembering
when look when to look at this killed a
relationship with him police it was good
glasses he still insisted on makeup so I
probably hours we in that it and what
was that life and tossed us a little bit
about playing right now so I would have
three to five hours in the chair morning
and you know Mike Smithson and special
effects makeup team they are number one
they're really cool
so it was really a fast process and you
know time that I just kind of known into
what was going to go on that day we've
got some music and there's a lot of fun
so it's definitely not comfortable
something yet to get used to and we had
to do a live cast a couple weeks before
the shoots they covered me in goop and
it was a crazy experience but yes some
some things that my martial arts
training does then and the focus helped
me just get through them it's a lot of
fun and sometimes I'd look in the mirror
and saying like hope I would surprise
myself and then I get done with the day
and take out my makeup and everybody
likes course Joe Guidice Ellen's
woodless books tell me yeah I saw yes
you are look part of it's been fun and
but obviously the Silver Surfer joke
went over so well I'm going to keep
doing them so I thought we'd jump ahead
the this is not a big secret guide we
just wanted to let folks know the beauty
of the show is that the people that are
the fish-out-of-water are the heroes of
our show and so they come to earth
they're not really prepared they are
being hunted and they make a friend and
make a friend in a character named
Louise who is an original character that
is from Earth it has some special
knowledge and loz that like being I
think literally the only person has it
didn't have powers
Metin doesn't talk about that melis is
great I mean for my characters like
there was a sort of levity that that was
there in material in the script that I
really enjoyed doing that sort of meet
up firmly determined maybe what they get
is one yes we have we excited we're
going to do a half-hour sitcom called
geez Louise just mad Ellen in it talking
no one that should go on an episode sure
so there you again hate soup Anson when
you and I first started talking about
playing this role as I
pshoo earlier on you know we told you
that there was not going to be any
dialogue and and oddly enough that was
what intrigues me the most deep talking
about how how you came to all and then
and then ultimately the the language to
you only share with music yeah I I just
I couldn't imagine ever coming across
this acting challenged again so
everybody wanted to leave at it and Jeff
being the very smart man he is knew what
I would ask for he mmediately offered
help finding help within the some
linguistics and signing community and I
was first I wanted it to be very
seriously and not since face value
I knew that I was going to begin by
learning how science systems work I
started watching not just items but
Orchestra conductors and I started
building a lexicon but he'll be the most
of having a collaborator who took it
seriously I Zaida and asked for me to
send her videos of my homework stylish
because to do my own one and I think
it's arisen I worked very well in that
capacity I could have done it without
her now I really you had the other path
which is which we don't exactly seen
that scene but when both speaks to the
rest of them you are the one of us
translate for everyone else so what was
it like
I mean I as those were some saw the
scripts you you saw what you see singing
but it you didn't know the physical
manifestation that was going to happen
now is basically a scene Wow I would
look at the scenes and I go there's a
good part of my part and then I realize
I have a most part I was it was really
interesting because the duality of that
and we normally are really playing off
somebody and so these emotions in them
again
you know I think we work so well
together because there was so much
emotion but I could see me that I could
get that it was easy on my side but then
I have to also be able to say it that
other people can understand it it wasn't
it was it was much easier win and like
something you just saw when I'm speaking
spork and everyone else because that's
how it goes but it's like a more
intimate scene between the two of us I'm
just talking
and so it really it was a challenge but
it was a fun amazing challenge to learn
and and yet I couldn't send me the
videos and we was victims so it's not
just as if the court not industry like
hand puppets and I'm talking we have it
think so we went off to think we would
stop the scene so I know the words and
that if you pay attention throughout the
whole show you'll start to recognize
work and moments and so when he speaks I
will I'll be looking at it through my
bravery and there's a really interesting
relationship that you guys might catch
because I don't always say what he finds
word for word
that's one of the best things pulpit
intelligence of strong opinion and
you'll see a kind of having this
interesting grind as we communicate and
the relationship it's there you know
it's obviously husband and wife king and
queen and also I play as interpreter so
the really tough on role to try to
figure out but I couldn't possibly know
about whether it was yes it was
articulate or amazing and we obviously
were reverse sensitive to the destiny
and not in any way saying that we were
doing signing we
this was a language which both created
so that you could communicate typically
with producer
yeah actually didn't check assigned
against ASL in Rothman not to make sure
there's nothing was overlapping but I
didn't I've worked with as an ASL
consultant to learn sort of what were
the some of the underlying rules of ASL
that making more efficient and and that
helped ally rule one of these nipply see
in endings and those those first two
sequences is it's just the scope I mean
in one case you around the tunnel in the
other case you were on Webber said how
did you approach that that the
particulars look what it is that we had
and it really when we started talk about
that design you had a vision it that I
think really helped sell the story in
terms of the grandeur of the palace and
obviously that's just one room you
there's a whole city if you guys cannot
believe what it looks like yeah thank
you you are looking at all the movies
that are out there and seeing what were
some I mix and what doesn't work in IMAX
and then you need to also realize that
we makin television so it was a kind of
a mix between okay we need to design
steps that have skill also in height and
when we can move the camera forward the
set of sight works so you see a lot of
the movements of the camera also
something that I really like I like
scope like move the camera we moving the
camera in a different way than we know
we see on television to kind of see if
you do feeling and going into this world
repeating the things that I could see
and I think you get a lot
the our department and moment abilities
Nass except that I used he hi
and that are like Freeland degrees
visible in all sizes so I couldn't be
low angle with the with the actress to
show the scope of this whole thing it
was there ever was any you this is this
was a like a little bit like this was
but I remember when you came in you this
was even all excited I do not know what
it was like why not you were beautifully
going on and if you were going to be
wearing these muslin and that and this
personality which in so many ways is you
I mean I think everybody here a bubble
from time very angry and dangerous to be
tell us about that
the temple plane board on it actually
kind of had a way of expressing myself
nice to cover stuff about myself as well
like drink call me would out kinda just
go around town and Rosic I'm doing very
important on ik things I really consider
a great discovery that guys a lot on I
mean know having the opportunity to
consistently just act houses ankles is
very exhilarating it don't try it
you know covering more bad especially
the fact of the size and scope it may be
realized love have no idea my own
strength
oh my gosh again he hurts people like if
you cannot how to this man
it is one of the most painful make you
see any hand I ever get my hands on that
purposes like offer cam coming out like
on screen as well these and just hug me
back to things and got wealth joking
like this is it for he is the most
aggressive humble and my tripod coming
in Alliance and me Google be Pat what
was your schedule or gonna make Gordon
experience when we first met I said to
him I did you check Preston and he was
like all right but a lot of model set
out I like really stressed the wood and
any chance present some pieces like
making like fatal tent on it's like
gross 34 and I kid Chris my every day so
and nothing I stopped I just was very
often like I can do this all day
45 video updates even we're just walking
in trailer and thing might know as
primal I have found him than the people
on the ground so if if they and Gorgan
are completely acting on impulse sort of
the the end of the egg or in many ways
the relationship in mice and men can't
blink when you got the role of product
we explained to you that I you know not
an addition to being advising the king
and someone's looking sort of see the
world I both half empty and half full
simultaneously that you had to look
after this guy tell us what it was like
they fart out it was daunting I mean the
character is so or minimal physically
intellectually and spiritually that I'm
constantly challenged by being in the
position to to Clayton so I love never
felt that before where I'm kind of
positively catching it trying to would
catch him and it stretches me
in ways that I'm not used to so with any
it's great I think with us we started
just a very casual debate over what is
your favorite superpower very early on I
want I think it's still ongoing position
one of that you know I tell me what do I
want
why I think really everyone does no
matter what your answer is
and that started like distinctive but
the fact that you soup you can be
hardened through source open again which
makes blockage and also if you fly
utilize a gland on the ground you're not
strong enough for properly and angry
died
[Music]
didn't respond to our different anyone
we wanted a little bit before about how
we don't really see Maximus and villain
but I mean I think a lot of people know
you from the other television show you
have a lot of concerns you bastard
how did you come to terms with that and
when you came on board you know house
about mattress yeah my my fear was that
and because the rise of continue this
Maximus guy was and it was like oh it
looks like I'm doing the same thing
again on a really cost you know at fear
of being typecast and I descended doing
you know she's repeating myself and
playing but then as we discuss it more
and more I realized that wasn't at all
what we were trying to create his show
in and your enthusiasm and vision and
really kind of inspired me actually to
kind of think well I think we can make
something really interesting from his
character and how's the story from from
a certain perspective of of this young
man who you know he went to his
terrigenesis and he became nothing and
you know in within this society which is
all about power you have to be where he
is the low to low and he kind of you
know he's called about a notary he's
really not working on the mind is
because he's the brother of the king and
even though if anybody's he would make a
much better thing because he consulted
case the amount of people as you know he
has you know you see there is that
there was some friendship in the past
with mezuzot and he feels that kind of
lost and he's become ignored really and
by a balloon so that kind of motivate is
one of them on to further south as well
as saving the II feel so sorry for the
VN in where he is revolution and poor
thinker and he thinks that he can
jarringly change the world for the back
of all people yet and that's probably
kind of worries when we find him in this
series but then you know and ruthless if
you believe that in order to make this
happen
he even singly altitude and he doesn't
like Haley loves its harmony you know
they're the only family he has been it's
a lonely world but you know is sort of
belief in boys doing and I even if he
thinks it's right and when you know when
he really saying it is like you know
ahead and he's just trying to stop
suffering so yeah and then you know the
cost of the decisions that we make
originally start so like corrupt Amin
it's a very secure story like you know
Padma best hot boy so that's why I
really want to do it in a collective
sense
[Applause]
[Music]
in the middle walk and that you are
literally the woman between the two
brothers consoles sitting up here but
but and and I think one of the things
that we talked about from their
beginning is how important it is that
producer isn't just an extension of both
and how do you bring that into the
character one was already on the page I
think that's a marvelous well as if
there's such strong female characters so
soon
you know your baby part of Marvel's Peto
your chicken Terrace so that was for the
grass that and distances and as we were
going through it was he became develop
adulthood in you know the whole complex
was finding wasn't just going to be this
interpreter and as I said before you see
those moments where she challenges him
where she changes his words a little
where she's not willing to just stand
behind him and so that was from the
beginning and even from the audition
it's very apparent even I believe he
have no idea what we're auditioning for
all in a deep a speaks with imaginary
sides that disappear in 24 hours very
ominous scary when you're walking in and
so we're going to I want you to process
and I was going in for Margie's going to
be writing for automotive I'm going from
RG at the end just in the row videos I
want you to she'll just finish it by
saying but remember I am your queen and
I got all these beautiful high dilution
gift but I love Margie and that was the
insistence from day one from being in
the room it was just this presence that
she had to have and that started from
the audition and then it just continues
with every script that I thought so I
was so amazing to come into